if you are sending an email then your
email will go through a cloud of
Internet connections before it reaches
its destination and this is where the
term cloud came from where do you define
the computing cloud rather than the
cloud the internet really starts as soon
as the information or data leaves your
device so it starts with your Wi-Fi
perhaps connection at home this is the
start of the cloud but in terms of cloud
computing it really starts with the
cloud providers or with your connection
with the provider that will host your
data in the cloud so if you are for
example using a spreadsheet within
Google Documents your connection to the
cloud is the web browser your author a
spreadsheet on the web browser it exists
physically on a web page within your web
browser but as soon as your spreadsheet
is saved it travels through a number of
internet connection to the destination
into which is stored the best way to
think about the advantages of cloud
computing is to resemble it to
electricity plug a device into an
electrical socket
it just works if you plot more devices
they get powered up and they work and
you do not really care how the
electricity was generated you do not
care how it was transported or what you
need to do is to use it and at the end
of the each month you get a bill that
charges you for the amount of
electricity that you have consumed now
similarly with cloud computing you
utilize the cloud resources to get
things done you use cloud resources in
order to upload your pictures into
Apple's iCloud so that you can access it
from anywhere you use cloud resources in
order to
do some word processing using Google
Documents and you can also use cloud
computing to power a portal that allows
you to order pizza and you do not really
care how these data is stored and you do
not really also need to understand or
install any of the software that allows
you access to this data is not going to
upgrade it and you do not need to
maintain it this is taken care of by the
cloud providers similar to electricity
cloud computing provide elastic
computing resources that can grow or
shrink in accordance to your demand so
this demand might be very huge so we
need a lot of computing resources
similar to the resources that the BBC
requires to stream millions of
simultaneous videos when viewers are
watching are ended and final or it can
be a far smaller resource similar to a
personal website that you want to host
on the cloud and that has only a handful
of visitors per day not all technologies
that allow you to access data on the
Internet or the internal network our
cloud technologies for example if you
say that you have your own storage space
in the office or a term and there is a
facility that allows you to access your
own storage space when you are abroad
this is not in the domain of cloud
computing it becomes cloud computing if
the physical storage of your documents
is not under your control or in a
physical space that you have access to
the commercial use of the cloud
predominantly makes use of the
characteristic to be able to offer scale
on demand perhaps the most
example of that is is Domino's Pizza
Domino's Pizza for a long time now have
had a an online resource that allows you
to order pizza online in fact this year
62% of the overall sales the orders were
completed online the main problem is the
fact that they have a very varied demand
on these online resources it's very
difficult for them to forecast the
amount of resources that they will
require day in day out month in month
out a computing resource that can grow
and shrink according to demand works
absolutely perfectly and this is why
they migrated if you like their IT
infrastructure from in-house servers to
host the online Porter's for pizza
orders to the cloud or cloud computing